veamos si podemos encontrar el límite
cuando teta tiende a 0 de 1 - el coche
no detecta entre dos veces el seno
cuadrado de teta y como siempre pausa en
el vídeo y ver si pueden resolver esto
bien tal vez nuestra primera intención
sea decir que esto es lo mismo que el
límite cuando teta tiende a cero de 1 -
el coche no detecta entre el límite
cuando te sientas 0 de dos veces el seno
cuadrado de teta ahora estas dos
expresiones que podrían ser usadas para
definir una función van a ser continuas
y se grafican iban a ser continuas entre
está igual a cero entonces el límite va
a ser lo mismo que solo evaluarlas ente
está igual a cero entonces esto va a ser
igual a uno menos el coche no de cero
entre dos veces el seno cuadrado de cero
ahora coseno de cero es uno y uno menos
10 y abajo me quedaría el seno de cero
lo cual es cero al elevado al cuadrado y
multiplicarlo por dos vas a seguir
obteniendo cero
entonces tenemos este caso donde
llegamos a 0 sobre 0 y una vez más
tenemos esta forma indeterminada y lo
importante es que esta forma
indeterminada cuando tenemos 0 entre 0
no significa que aquí nos rendimos no
significa que el límite no existe sólo
significa que tal vez haya otras formas
para trabajar este límite si tenemos un
número diferente de 0 dividido entre 0
entonces si hay diríamos que límite no
existen pero en este caso vamos a ver
qué podemos hacer para tal vez plantear
esta expresión de una forma diferente
entonces digamos que esto de aquí es fx
le voy a poner ese nombre
fx es igual a 1 menos el coche no
detectan esto a su vez dividido entre
dos veces el seno cuadrado de teta y
veamos si podemos escribirlo de alguna
manera en la cual el límite cuando teta
tiende a cero no vaya a ser cero entre
cero y bueno aquí tenemos algunas
funciones trigonométricas así que tal
vez podamos usar nuestras identidades
trigonométricas para reducir
y lo que me llama la atención es que
abajo tenemos el seno cuadrado de teta y
sabemos una identidad pitagórica en
trigonometría que sale directo de la
definición del círculo unitario que usa
el seno y al coce no sabemos que el seno
cuadrado de teta más el coche no
cuadrado de teta
eso es lo mismo que uno o sabemos dicho
de otra manera que el seno cuadrado de
teta es igual a 1 - el coseno cuadrado
de teta entonces esto es igual a am y
déjame escribirlo
1 - el coche no detecta entre dos veces
1 - el coseno cuadrado de teta porque
eso es lo mismo que el seno cuadrado de
teta y tal vez te salte que uno menos en
nueve teta y el uno menos coste no
cuadrado de teta se pueden manipular de
tal manera que nos ayude a reducir un
poco esta expresión si te das cuenta
esto se puede ver como una diferencia de
cuadrados la parte de abajo es lo mismo
que a cuadrada menos b cuadrada porque
sabemos que esto se puede factorizar
como a más b
v entonces esto sería igual a 1 - el
coche no detecta esto a su vez dividido
entre 2
uno más el coche no detecta que a su vez
multiplica a uno menos el coche
beteta y ahora esto es muy interesante
porque tengo uno menos el coche no
detecta en el numerador y tengo uno
menos costes 9 teta en el denominador y
tal vez estemos muy tentados a decir
bueno vamos a cancelar este con este y
reduciremos y tendremos simplemente uno
en tren y tengo dos que multiplicamos a
uno más el coste 9 tan bueno son lo
mismo que dos más dos veces el coche no
de teta y podremos pensar estas dos
expresiones son realmente lo mismo y es
casi correcto ya que fx de kim está
definida cuando teta es igual a cero
mientras que ésta no está definida
cuando teta es igual a cero cuando teta
es igual a cero tenemos un cero en el
denominador y entonces lo que
necesitamos para que estas dos
expresiones sean iguales es decir que
eta debe de ser distinta de cero pero
ahora vamos a pensar de nuevo en el
límite esencialmente lo que queremos
hacer
entrar el límite cuánto te está 30 0 de
fx y no podemos sólo hacer una
sustitución directa si en realidad lo
tomamos seriamente porque podremos decir
si trato de poner el 0 aquí hay dice que
teta no puede ser 0 entonces fx no está
definida a 0 pero ten cuidado porque
esta expresión si está definida en 0
pero por otra parte esto nos dice que no
deberíamos aplicar el 0 a esta función
así que sabemos que podemos encontrar
otra función que sí esté definida en 0 y
que sea exactamente igual
fd x excepto en 0 pero lo que voy a
hacer es que esta nueva función si sea
continua en 0 entonces podemos decir que
gtx va a ser igual a 1 entre 2 más 2
veces el coche no de teta y luego
sabemos que este límite va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que el límite
cuando teta tiende a 0 dgt x de nuevo
estas dos funciones son idénticas
excepto que fx no está definida en teta
igual a 0 mientras que ge de x sí lo
están
los límites cuando teta tiende a cero
van a ser los mismos y lo hemos visto en
varios de los vídeos anteriores y sé que
muchos de ustedes están pensando porque
no solo hacer un poco de álgebra kim
cancelar esto de camps sustituir a theta
por cero y acabar bien podrían hacer eso
estoy seguro que así obtendrá la
respuesta pero es importante aclarar
matemáticamente lo que estás haciendo yo
sé que se cancelan este con este si
haces esto la expresión de repente se
vuelve definirán 0 y eso es porque estás
lidiando con una expresión diferente o
una definición de una función diferente
así que para aclarar si quieren decir
que esta es la función de la que están
buscando el límite deben de poner esta
restricción para asegurarse de que
tienen exactamente el mismo dominio pero
para nuestra suerte podemos decir que si
tuviéramos otra función que fuera
continua en ese punto es decir que no
tuviera un hueco ahí entonces los
límites serían equivalentes y ahora si
el límite cuando te traten de hacer o
deje de x
igual y ya que es continua en 0 podemos
sustituir 70 es igual a 1 entre dos más
dos veces el coste no de cero pero el
coste no es cero
es 1 entonces me queda uno entre dos más
dos déjame ver si estamos bien uno entre
dos más dos veces el coste no de cero
eso es lo mismo que a uno entre dos más
dos lo cual es lo mismo que un cuarto y
qué creés hemos terminado